hey youtubers is charlie so today we're
going to talk about Game of Thrones
characters that just do not give a crap
about the Iron Throne anymore chief
among them dragons obviously dragons
absolutely do not care for the Iron
Throne not that they ever did just
careful for spoilers through season four
we don't necessarily have to get into
book stuff so if you only watch the show
you should be just fine if you want to
add anybody to the list feel free this
is only going to be a top five so
there's there's no way everyone's gonna
make the list so here we go starting
with number five Braun this is almost a
cheap because he's like the king of not
caring about almost anything I think
maybe having sex like that's probably
cares about most having sex and filling
his pocket with someone else's gold it
seems like he's been Tyrians best friend
but really I think he's only been his
best friend as long as Tyrion has
supported his request for more gold
bronze like an afternoon delight love
the one you're with kind of person I
don't think he's obsessed with money you
know yes he's a mercenary he works for
whoever pays him but he's not a slave to
the acquisition of wealth that the
Lannisters are I think a really good
example of his character is the last
time he saw Tyrion in the black cells
his friend was getting ready to get his
head chopped off and it just seemed like
he almost didn't care about anything he
was kind of sad to see him go but he was
like well what are you gonna do now that
brawn is the Lord though I'm interested
to see how it changes his behavior in
season 5 the show has actually turned
him into a main character like if you
look at the season 5 cast list he's
actually a main character in the books
not so much moving on to number four
though Sansa Stark this is a pretty easy
1i I think she mostly just cares about
staying alive Littlefinger seems like he
has this very creepy grand plan for her
she kind of started to pick up on it at
the end of season 4 like she dyed her
hair they were there obviously gonna go
on the run but I don't think that she
really cares about who sits on the Iron
Throne least of all herself you think
that the surviving Starks would care
most about finding the rest of their
family of all them Sansa has kind of
been the slowest to get her ass in gear
that's why in season 5 i'm really
excited to see if she does anything
crazy like if she comes to the breaking
point like if aria and jon snow are
starting to go through big character
transformations maybe Sansa is going to
as well there's this thing called
narrative proximity that George are
Martin is a big fan of where big things
happen to similar characters you have
the battle between Brienne and the hound
and then you have the battle between
Oberyn Martell in the mountain they
changed a little bit
from the books but you get the idea if
all the Starks share something in common
you would expect that they would be on
similar character arcs even if the very
specific things that happen to them are
different if one goes through a big
change gets a big call to action you
expect the same thing to happen to the
other Starks I think it bodes well for
Santa's character if anybody has
actually read the news just as a quick
side note do you wonder if bryan singer
or the people at fox soft footage from
Game of Thrones Season five Of sophie
Turner and cast her as the new Jean Grey
based on that she hasn't done a whole
lot of other stuff but it is just an
interesting idea just something to keep
in the back of your mind moving on to
number three Ramsay Bolton formerly
known as Ramsay snow I'd say before
Roose Bolton legitimize them the only
thing that Ramsey cared about was his
father's approval you could argue that
Ramsey cares about fitting into whatever
he thinks his father thinks is important
and Roose Bolton obviously cares a lot
about the Iron Throne I don't think
that's the case though I think Ramsay is
just like a little kid on the playground
he just wants to smash everyone else's
toys he absolutely does not care at all
about sitting on the Iron Throne
wouldn't it be crazy though wouldn't it
be crazy if he ended up on the Iron
Throne that would be more insane than
Samwell ending up on the Iron Throne the
crazy thing about Ramsey though is
because he's not a POV character you
don't spend a whole lot of time in his
head so you only think about him when
other characters are thinking about him
the show makes it a little bit easier
because you do get scenes in third
person but even if he ends up in a
position of power I still don't think
that he cares about power itself moving
on to number two Jon Snow Jon Snow knows
nothing of desire for the Iron Throne
he's one of the few characters who
understands the threat of the White
Walkers who cares about power when you
have an army of White Walkers slowly
marching on you it remains to be seen
but do you think that more people in
positions of power whether they be in
Westeros are in the East will start
taking the White Walkers more seriously
the only person who really took them
seriously was Varys and he's gone now I
can't think of any of the other big
characters there at least the characters
that are on the show who still care
about what's going on at the wall or
even read the messages that the Ravens
bring Jamie seems like the most sensible
character left but I don't think he
cares about Jon Snow or what's going on
at the ball at all and my number one
pick Arya Stark totally easy definitely
the queen of not giving a crap it seems
like she's given up all hope
your family again she knows Jon Snow's
at the wall but based on the craziness
in the season finale it seems like she
thinks her best chance of survival is
just getting the hell out of Westeros I
don't think she even has a plan inside
her head she just knows jack and a guard
gave of the coin and said she could use
it to come to Braavos if she wanted it's
probably the best decision that anyone
could ever make various is probably the
smartest person in King's Landing and he
did the exact same thing not that he
went to Braavos just that he got the
hell out let's just forget about the
books for sec and think about the
characters on the show there was a bit
of a power shake up in King's Landing
last season Cersei Jamie the Tyrells
they're all still around do you think
that any of those characters will change
their mind about wanting power over the
kingdom like wanting to sit on the Iron
Throne winter is very literally coming
so it seems like anyone at the end of
this year at the end of season five
still clinging to the Iron Throne is
going to end up being a tragic character
it's like the smart thing to do is just
like back up a few steps hit the pause
button and say okay maybe maybe we'll
take care of this big problem over here
and then we'll get back to fighting over
the throne I'm really hoping we get some
crazy white Walker scenes in season 5
it'd be kind of stupid if a whole year
went by and then we got to the season
six and they all just suddenly show up
at the wall like surprise [ __ ]
that's why I'm totally willing to
tolerate like non-book scenes like the
scene we got in season four up and the
lands of always winter here's my big
question for you guys let me know in the
comments who's your favorite character
who you know seemed like they really
cared about the Iron Throne in season
one and at this point we're getting into
season five absolutely changed their
mind does not care about being in power
at all those are always the most fun
characters to talk about like the ones
that do big 180s Jaime Lannister is a
good example I don't think he ever
wanted to be on the Iron Throne but he's
a character that's done a big 180 just
as a bonus pic just for fun I'll say the
queen of thorns probably a character
that does not care about the Iron Throne
although it seems like she does she
always seems like she has like a really
grand plan she's been around a long time
very clearly good at playing the game of
thrones but it seems like she cares more
about her family than she does about
being in power she sees that Marjorie
really wants the Iron Throne so she's
just gonna help her out just because
it's fun and she can that's why her
scenes with Tywin Lannister last season
were probably some of the best I mean
not only the actors amazing both the
actors but it makes you stop thinking
about it is this like high fantasy
narrative and you see two old people
playing
a game of chess so just be sure to write
in your favorite characters that you
think just absolutely do not care about
the Iron Throne big characters small
characters anybody that's kind of a
funny thing about the show like the show
is called Game of Thrones even though
the book series is called a song of ice
and fire it's like where we are in the
narrative yes there are people still
fighting for power but that's not even
the biggest story anymore it's slowly
shifting to this story about fire versus
ice you know White Walkers versus the
red God that's just like a problem with
TV where it's like they can't change the
name of the show and because there's
more people that watch the show then
read the books people think of it as
game of thrones even though technically
it's Song of Ice and Fire in related
news speaking of outside fire and ice
stuff so if you guys been playing the
video game the game of thrones telltale
Game they're releasing chapter 2 or
episode 2 whatever you want to think
about it right after the Super Bowl so
it's going to be februari third we'll
get to see a bunch of other location so
we'll get to see some of the other main
characters including Kit Harington is
Jon Snow so it'll be a lot of fun one of
the really cool things about doing a
licensed game regardless of what you
think of the game is is that they can
use actors from the show because it's an
HBO Telltale Games collaboration I think
the only complaint people had about
episode 1 of the game was that it was
kind of simple like if you're a really
hardcore fan like you're into the books
are into the show it's like a fairly
simple narrative that it follows I'll do
more videos on that whenever they
release it but that's coming really soon
so keep your eyes peeled and don't
forget next week is when the imax run
starts so if you want to be one of the
first people to see the season five
trailer go to one of the imax showings
although they will post the trailer
online just because we're so close to
that i think my next bonus video
probably will be a review the imax
trailer so be sure to subscribe to get
that that'll probably post on thursday
congratulations to the winner of this
week's giveaway Mughal berries you get
your choice of amazon gift card or you
can get a copy of the telltale Game the
game of thrones game since they're
really saying episode 2 real soon just
send me a message on my channel with
which one you want because of the
trailer next week the giveaway in that
video will be for two copies of the game
so there'll be two winners I wanted to
double the giveaway for the trailer
video just because it's such a big deal
we've been waiting it for so long so
we're all going to flip out and have a
good time all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber leave a comment
whenever I post that video nice and
simple so while you guys wait for that
it's only going to be like four or five
days so it's not going to be that long
you can click here for my
Mance Rayder character video and you can
click here to learn all about the
Citadel maesters thank you so much for
watching let's all high five I'll see
you guys tomorrow
you